cette année en champagne la récolte n'a
pas été fameuse mais pour simca chrysler
récemment entré dans le groupe peugeot
citroën
soixante dix huit sera un excellent
millésime qui porte la firme à plus de
11% du marché et l'horizon automoto vous
a présenté en janvier dernier années la
principale raison mais avec la sx voici
un nouveau modèle plus puissant encore
mieux équipée et dotée en série de
l'automatisme c'est une véritable
automatique avec convertisseur de couple
et boîtes à trois rapports
au plancher nous trouvons donc le
classique ses lecteurs mais pour
maintenir des performances comparables à
celles de l'horizon gls
il a fallu adopter le moteur 14 142 83
chevaux de la 308 gti mais sur l'horizon
et 6 nous découvrons aussi le cruise
control qui nous vient des états unis
c'est un dispositif automatique qui
régule la vitesse du véhicule et la
maintient constante à une valeur choisie
par le conducteur
[Musique]
non
en fait la grande première c'est bien
sûr l'ordinateur de voyage en réalité un
calculateur sophistiqués on peut
toujours y trouver leur mais en appuyant
sur un clavier
nous apprenons immédiatement que nous
sommes partis depuis une heure dix que
nous avons parcouru 60 6 km 3 que nous
avons consommé 6 litre 4 soit 9 8 6 aux
100 kilomètres à une vitesse moyenne de
56,2 km heure c'est remarquable
et cet appareil dépasse le cadre du
gadget
encore faut-il qu'ils durent longtemps
cet équipement valorise considérablement
les six proposés à 33 1800 francs
c'est une berline polyvalente qui a fait
l'unanimité sur sa tenue de route son
freinage et son confort moyennement
habitable lpech net mort par une
direction très démultiplier et malgré
cela extrêmement lourde
[Musique]